c'est martin soucy qui est pdg
d'alliance de l'industrie touristique du
québec qui est notre invité ce soir
bonsoir
bonsoir donc oui le gros de la saison
touristique quand même tire à sa fin
maintenant qu'on n'ouvre que les
frontières sont ouvertes a à peu près
tout le monde il reste l'inde et le
maroc là où il ya des suspensions de
vols pour l'instant quelles sont vos
attentes
écoutez effectivement la clientèle
internationale nous aide beaucoup en
automne pour prolonger la saison
estivale qui est importante pour donc
les entreprises touristiques on sait que
cette année les québécois ont largement
visité les régions du québec par contre
dans les villes comme montréal et québec
qui est ok 70 % des volumes tous
internationaux à ce moment là ça a été
c'est pour ça que ça explique dans la
pandémie où les sangliers les livres
parce qu'ils rendent proportion donc
l'expérience actuellement c'est que ça
puisse repartir pour le cinéma on
s'attend pas à des miracles à court
terme on pense que 2022 en fonction
aussi de l'argent plus on est loin plus
faut qualifier son voyage donc cette
variable barbade influence l'important
c'est de rester en tête de liste des
destinations à voyager dans le futur
pour les marchés où on s'adresse par
exemple les français on ne travaille que
pour les rebords au québec et de
repartir progressivement dans le fond la
machine pour que les une entreprise peut
générer des retombées économiques
importants dans les régions et gagner à
nouveau est-ce qu'on a quand même vu
depuis un mois la frontière est ouverte
aux américains est ce qu on a noté la
présence de beaucoup d'américains chez
nous depuis le 9 ou
écouter ses on a noté la présence
d'américains ça a été plus marquée avec
l'ouverture de la frontière avec
l'ontario n'ont eu beau plus tôt et sont
arrivées de touristes américains mais
c'est normal une question également de
reprendre confiance on est très chanceux
avec la gestion de deux fois qu'on est
une destination sécuritaire comme le
second plus de demeurer également mais
ça va se faire progressivement et nos
attentes à cet égard au québec on savait
qu'il fallait être raisonnable 1 le
retour des touristes les entreprises
pour pouvoir retrouver fait le plein
potentiel dans la plaque les 4 milliards
de dollars à l'économie si tout s est
rangé leur botteur reportant le disais
tantôt le quart du volume des détours et
centaines de noms mais c'est 54 % des
dépenses sont générés au québec en
matière touristique donc c'est important
mais ça va se faire progressivement et
on pensait vraiment la reprise doit se
faire sentir beaucoup plus
significativement en 2010 est-ce que
avec le retour des européens des
américains ça peut être une bonne chose
pour l'industrie touristique mais est ce
que vous prévoyez quand même
ralentissement du tourisme québécois et
du tourisme ontarien qui a été galvanisé
dans le tourisme intérieur durant la
pandémie
une excellente question parce que la
population québécoise voyage beaucoup à
l'extérieur des limites ça représente 8
milliards de dollars la population va
dépenser ailleurs donc je disais tantôt
camélia qui rend plus millions obsaar
donc il faut être capable
progressivement de 1 de continuer à
valoriser le québec les régions les
québécois ont peu fait le tour de tout
ce qui a fait on a une superbe
destination et en même temps il va
falloir pour avoir la part des touristes
internationaux dont il faudra être
prévoyant dans les faits de bakou même
que ça pourrait créer un
particulièrement 2022 mais on est
confiant avec les atouts qu'on a de sa
puce est balancé progressivement il ya
eu énormément d'intérêt de la population
pour des régions qui était méconnu
jusqu'à maintenant donc on va vraiment
pouvoir rebondir là dessus l'année
prochaine mais c'est effectivement
phénomène ça fait partie des défis
nombreux défis qu'on relève depuis 18
mois parmi les nombreux défis ya le
manque de main d'oeuvre bien sûr 26
mille emplois à combler pour les
prochaines saisons touristiques dans le
fond monsieur souci est ce qu'on est
prêt à accueillir plus de touristes en
ce moment au québec compte tenu du
manque de main d'oeuvre
les entreprenants touristique les
employés ont fait des heures important
c'est certain que la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre par exemple les heures
d'ouverture ou encore les jo la capacité
hôtelière un hôtel de 100 chambres
encore et 87 en mesure d'entretenir donc
ce que ça limite pour le moment les gens
ont vraiment travaillé mis l'épaule à la
roue on a accueilli de façon chaleureuse
mais ce qu'à long terme cela peut
freiner la reprise de notre industrie
mais effectivement si notre enjeu numéro
un on n'est pas tout seul aux prises
avec eux c'était cet élément-là de
pénurie de main-d'oeuvre qu'on voit
venir depuis plusieurs années mais on
sortait de la crise et plus important
encore et c'est quoi la super league
dans il y en a plusieurs
des solutions à court terme pour aider
les entreprises des travailleurs
expérimentés qui aiment les horaires
atypiques les gens la retraite vont
aimer les horaires atypiques on peut
avoir par exemple en touriste est une
industrie ou créer du bonheur mais on
peut être adaptée mais ça fera des
crédits d'impôts des mesures fiscales
vont être importantes pour pour qui les
inciter à revenir l'autre élément c'est
le programme de travailleurs temporaires
étrangers pour lequel louis a eu des
améliorations récemment mais avec encore
un allègement des processus
administratifs pourraient donner un coup
de main pour aller chercher cette
médaille dans un futur qui prête à
travailler il ya un excellent contingent
par exemple de travailleurs français
quitte en cuisine ou dans certains
autres qui sont en mesure par la mégane
qui pourrait venir nous donner un coup
de main dans l'industrie donc sur tous
les éléments également vu que je suis
pro cap et c'est heureux le programme ce
programme entraînement doit laisser
place à cause des mesures de création
d'emplois pour ramener les travaille à
la fois dans les régions c'est ce que
nous verrons martin soucy merci d'avoir
été avec nous c'est un grand plaisir
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit